we've learned 16 year old sierra halseth
is in juvenile hall
according to metro police and her
boyfriend 18 year old aaron guerrero
is at the clark county detention center
they were taken into custody in salt
lake city
utah 10 days ago after metro police say
they were on the run
they both face a murder charge the head
of metro homicide previously told us
this is an especially disturbing case
there's no question they had made
attempts to dismember his body the
investigation began friday april 9 when
lieutenant ray spencer says
police found the body of 45 year old
daniel halseth inside a home
his money and car stolen lieutenant
spencer tells the eye team there were
attempts to start a fire to cover up the
crime
and investigators also found tools we've
recovered a chainsaw
circular saw and a handsaw inside the
house that was recently purchased and
used investigators say the teens were
planning to run away together to
california and their parents told them
they couldn't see each other
in the days leading up to the alleged
murder on march 21st
daniel halseth posted on facebook i love
you so much daughter you
are so strong and brave we got this
sierra health says attorney michael
sanft
tells the i-team her family is asking
for privacy to be respected
during this overwhelming time for all
parties concerned
after the teens were taken into custody
in utah on april 13
guerrero's attorney gabriel grasso told
the i-team
his advice was not to fight extradition
now you know reality sets in and we have
to see what's up and what the evidence
shows
the teens are expected to be in court on
april 28th
bail has not yet been set reporting from
downtown las vegas vanessa murphy 8 news
now
now we can also tell you according to
nevada's state law a defendant who is
age 16 and older
is automatically charged as an adult for
a murder charge
as the i-team first reported sierra
halseth is also the daughter of former
nevada state senator
elizabeth halseth